hey everyone it's Mike from motl flows
here and guess what I'm back you know
it's been a while it's been over a month
since I made a video and you know I I
did get a uh quite a few emails from
people asking you know hey you know is
everything all right you know why why we
got no videos um you know my my
customers know that I've been um you
know still doing the weekly training
seminars you know I I like to keep the
good stuff for the customers um but you
know I've been sick honestly for the
last couple of weeks uh and I'm finally
just getting over it you know I still
got that sore throat and you know I've
been working on some things uh some
projects that haven't been wanting to
get done for a while so you know I'm
sort of wrapping up those projects and
you know I might give you guys a little
sneak peek into um you know the quote
orderflow algo that I've been working on
for uh quite a bit which should make uh
you know at least my trading um a bit
easier so um you know I'm going to just
talk make a quick uh video for you guys
here today you know today in the snps um
you know we had very uh qu I say quiet
session you know it was one of those
misleading sessions where it looked like
it was kind of uh unchanged for the day
but we had kind of had a decent you know
it was Market was kind of weak most of
the morning um you know cash opened up
here this morning this is uh November 6
just hard to believe it's November
already it's like Thanksgiving feels
like it's next week even though it's
still another couple weeks away um you
know right off the cash
open you see we hit that high and then
you got very strong negative Delta now
granted you know - 1237 in the Delta is
a big number but it's coming in you know
right within the first couple minutes of
the cach open so I'm not too surprised
to see a big Delta number but it's a
negative Delta number which is not good
then again it's followed by a strong
negative Delta as well- 1578 so the
first three bars of the cach open strong
positive Delta going into the high then
at the high strong negative Delta
followed by an even stronger negative
Delta
and what happens is the market starts to
sell off but more importantly every time
you would start to get a little bit of a
rally you see the rallies just sort of
Peter out I mean honestly what you're
seeing since the cash open here at the
8:30 is mostly negative Deltas just
seeing them down here on the bottom
right and anytime you'd string together
some positive Deltas like you see here
you get you know 178 344 okay that's
just two but 84 94 500 then- 4 400 plus
967 so you know you're starting to
string together some decent positive
Deltas you know 5 58 plus 967 then you
get a 166 here it's kind of thinning out
then you get Negative Delta then you get
a small Delta of 127 then a negative
Delta then even a stronger negative
Delta so you know you're starting to
build some positive Delta momentum going
in here and then it just came in and W
it sort of ate back all your positive
Delta here you had the strong 900 here
then the next bar here- 478 so these two
bars here sort of took out whatever you
were building right in here over the
last you know from 854 to 902 all that
positive Delta that you were
accumulating it just all of a sudden
gave it all right back in the period of
two bars and then it goes down trades
new lows okay and then you start getting
again another half parted rally um you
know the low had negative Delta then the
bar afterwards positive 346 posit 69
positive 728 positive 300 and thinking
hey this is it now we're going to
probably Rally from this low up to the
highs maybe and you start going up then
where's your strong Delta where's it
continuing you got - 33 posi
59- 147 and then you look hey I got nice
positive Delta a th000 maybe this is it
maybe this is the move that's that's
finally going to happen what happens it
comes right back next bar positive 1 68
Delta followed
by
1213 then the bar afterwards minus 1,000
so
literally these two bars again all that
positive Delta momentum you were
building up here it gave it all right
back within the next two bars just as it
did with these two bars here okay so
what are you expecting you expect this
Market to really start to Rally no
because you know now you've had two
instances I mean taken away this cash
open where the bar with the strong um
Delta coming in here okay take that away
because you know that's the cash open
Monday morning um it's going to do what
it's going to do but you had a little
rally here and then it just gave all
that back in two bars another little
rally here gave it all back within two
bars okay and then you get another
little rally going here now this one's
starting to look maybe okay you see nice
strong Delta 538 here then 63 okay not
the end of the World netive - 273 again
not the end of the world postive
144 - 79 postive 158 POS 293 POS 6 608
hey this is it green green Green another
green bar positive
421 positive
414 okay it looks like it's building
right Delta's getting stronger here 158
293 um
608 okay 400 okay 421 exactly
414 then the red candle -200 and2 -
422 it's not looking good now it's not
coming in with strong selling in two
bars after you sort of peak out here
right it's just - 200 - 422 you know the
previous bars you got 158 293 600 421
414 but this is where it gets a little
bit interesting cuz it even though it's
going up it's going up on slightly less
Delta 608 than
421 - 4 44
now 421 to 414 is what seven contracts
now is that enough to say that the Delta
is really declining because again it's
only seven contracts um it's not like
it's declined from 421 to 214 you know
like 200 contracts it's only declined
seven
but technically it did decline as it's
going up which again is not a good sign
again maybe you're not convinced and you
just want to see how what's going to
Peter out negative Delta negative Delta
negative Delta and then - 688 right here
okay- 596 so
again little bit of a rally gave it all
back within two bars little bit of a
rally gave it all back within two bars
little bit of a rally that this time the
Delta was kind of decreasing on the way
up although minuscule very it's marginal
at best but technically it is declining
um
- 200 - 400 - 200 -
600 excuse me so it is
declining so they've had three little
rallies that were just given back really
quick in the
Delta sorry I got to drink some
water do you think this Market is going
to
rally at all it's only 9:44 in the
morning so if you get any little bit of
a rally maybe you might want to sell it
right here you get a little bit of rally
plus you this Delta is plus 800 and then
just two minus 200us 95 maybe you can
sell it in here okay little bit I don't
even call this a rally but again you
could probably sell that in here any of
these little rallies you should be
thinking maybe these are opportunities
for me to sell now you know this sort of
concept is a little bit more advanced
for some traders to understand because
you're you're really just eyeballing
what's happening in the
Delta as the market rallies followed by
when the market drops it drops pretty
quick right in this case it dropped over
two bars over two bars this one it took
about four bars for it to really give
that convincing sign right it's - 200 -
400 - 200 -
600 again you got the one bar with big
positive Delta
887 that's just all negative Delta right
you're looking at -200 - 95 - 128 what
are you waiting for okay I know there's
selling coming here I should be getting
short 84 and a half right it trades up
to 85 or it drops down to you know the
81 is area here right get a little bit
of a bounce up here some Deltas 213
288 followed by negative Delta more
negative Delta if you're getting short
in here around 80 2 81 and A2 you know
it's a nice quick move down into the 70s
you know 79 78 and A2 area again another
little rally up here not convincing
rally up here look as you're going up
Delta is Just 4 3
268 - 64 pos4 - 310 - 108 - 101 right
you could be looking to sell it in here
on the way back down now you later in
the day we did make that low that we did
have that nice Rally from down um here
excuse
me this is one of my favorite trades to
take this is the bullish Divergence
right the new equal low with positive
Delta and a bullish ratio of the 44
which tells me some form of price
exhaustion taking place down here
followed by another two bars later you
got this nice stacked B and balance with
two Thin prints two zero prints in the
bar
bar I apologize for my coughing Market
started to go sideways pulled back into
that area where you had that strong
aggressive buying the market rallied
pulled back down now this Zone here
right this is the where the Stacked
imbalance is right here you can see it
just came right down to the top where
here tested
it where am I here here we go okay
it went back up a little bit came back
down again we haven't broken the low yet
low is 4 and a quart we got down to 4
and a half um before we start turning
back up there but you know these ratio
and divergences whenever I see them
people ask me what's my favorite trade
to take this is one of them you know I
don't have one favorite trade I have
sort of a handful of Trades I like to
take because again you know Market you
can only trade what the market gives you
and there are different market
conditions and any give moment okay so
you know something like ratio and
Divergence may only happen a few times a
day because it's going to happen at the
high of the day or the low of the
day so anyway guys um yeah that's about
uh you know some of the interesting
order flow for today you know it's
interesting you know I get
uh get some strange uh emails I got an
email today from somebody and he's very
up said at me um he says oh the
orderflow trader software doesn't work
right he says it doesn't work on the the
new version which is just crap because
I'm running literally on the the new
version 8.1.2 point0 which is the most
current version that's out there but you
sent me a chart of the bonds okay five
minute chart right you see we're trading
11229 okay his
chart okay he's got his chart Centered
for some reason I have no
clue
at
149 was at 145 I forget he's got it like
this it's got his chart set like this at
at trading at 149 even or 145 even I can
see all the data on the bottom because
he sent me a screenshot of the chart
saying oh there's nothing on my chart
doesn't work so I S nice email back
saying hey you know what you need to
Center your chart right on ninja Trader
there's this little thing up here on the
upper right hand side of the
screen to click click to rescale if you
just put your mouse button over you see
right it says click to rescale because
of course you're not going to get
anything on your
screen if you're at the 140 handle right
145 146 147 14 48
149 all you got to do is just click that
button for some reason doesn't want to
but whatever but anyway guys I'll show
you what well thing that I've been
working on lately is this my orderflow
algo thing
um and again it deals a bit with fine
demand it deals with uh swing highs
swing lows right which ones are tradable
because you know markets trade from
swing low swing High swing low swing
high right and down now again you know
not all swing highs and swing lows are
going to be tradable okay and you know
you want to find the best
ones okay and that's you know sort of
the rabbit hole I've been going down um
for the last month or so month and a
half actually a bit longer I've just
been getting very intense on it the last
couple of weeks I think that's one of
the reasons why I got sick with that in
the weather when trick-or-treating in
snowstorm here in Chicago suburbs um on
Halloween it's bizarre we got like an
inch and a half of snow on
on Halloween but um you know we've been
burning the midnight oil uh you know
trying to get this thing uh programmed
correctly you know what I'm exactly
looking for and you know getting back to
a conversation that I've had before with
things like supply and demand and and
Order flow on certain Market markets
right follow it much better than others
right markets that don't have a lot of
retail participation where it's just the
traders that are trading
it in my opinion sometime sometimes
often times follow order flow much
better why it's because really what's
driving the market is supply and demand
it's not speculative money so for
example okay there's a contract out
there I mean most of us we're we're from
familiar with the interest rates right
bonds 10 years 5 years but not everybody
understands that there's newer contracts
out there called the ultas right there's
Ultra bonds UV there's ultr tens TN
right and you know the people that are
training them are the banks you don't
have a lot of retail speculation in them
the way you do with you know some of the
currencies this is
um eurocurrency chart or even like the
e- minis or Mees right a lot of stock
indices there's a huge retail
participation part in there but if you
look at a market like TN Ultra
tens you know following orderflow
following supply and demand it just
blows all these other markets out of the
water people always ask me what's the
best Market to trade well it depends you
know why do you want to trade do you
want to trade to make money or you'll
trade for Action you know because they
they'll say oh I want to trade to make
money well whatk markets are you trading
well I'm trading NASDAQ why oh because I
saw some guy posting on YouTube or some
guy posting on Facebook that they made
uh $975 on their Sim account you know
three days in a row okay so what why
don't you stick to the markets that are
easy to read right that that can help
you as a Trader um understand the market
and you know Trade It
successfully right so if so this is like
why we've been veloping that's why I I
spent a lot of time you know with my
program over the last month to work on
this one because this is something that
is you know definitely I I've been
wanting to get this done for my own
personal
trading I don't know if we're going to
even release it to the public or or what
but uh you know because I said I develop
a lot of tools um you know just for my
own use and you know supply and demand
when you you couple it with order flow
just blows everything out of the water
right and again you know this is ultra
tens right I mean you can look at a
market like this was currencies okay
that's a look at this even if you go
down to right if you're a day trader
right scalper in and out of the market
very quick right you know 15-second
chart you say I don't to trade a 15sec
chart could you trade a chart like this
if you know where these levels are
right okay so you try to get long
here okay you take a bad you know you
get stopped out here right I have these
zones there's a whole concept of trading
with supply and demand right because you
can trade pullbacks into Supply right if
I know Supply is coming in here and
Market trades down comes back up into
Supply
here that's my place I could get short
again comes back up I can get short
again it hasn't broken through this
level right this a zone is drawn out
here starting here so you can see how
these levels are holding right and look
at this markets are going up pulled back
right within that zone right that's why
we draw out these zones so we know
exactly where you know where we could
add on like so you know say I were to
buy this pullback I buy here I know that
if this Market comes down to this level
I'm out that's a 15-second
chart right again you whether you're
trading a 15-second chart I don't know a
50 tick chart right I mean they they
look a bit alike honestly um I mean you
could even go into you know other
contracts right that's euro currency um
you know British
pound right how British pound looks
okay again you know that's a 50 tick
chart right you know may some people
don't like a 50 tick chart they want to
stick on a more traditional one minute
chart U maybe some people want to trade
faster a 30 second
chart
right you know if you know you be
selling up here you should be selling
this High not necessarily this High you
tried to sell this High okay started
coming back up and this high is the one
you can sell right again from you know
124 this area in right in here you know
the 25 down to you know down even down
to here to 20 right you got this this a
lot of time in here you could be selling
it
where's the trade down to where's your
next Buy Signal down here 12380 right
get this little bit of a rally now there
was a Zone drawn out here but it just
didn't qualify to get the triangle for
the cell cell came in a little bit later
down here again 71 73 down in here all
the way down into the
40s right you know at the previous day
right was Friday look at that and I me
this was a beautiful day up I mean 120
you know before the number came out
right in here it was given a Buy Signal
okay did have the short here that didn't
really pan out but then you're getting
long again here
52 all the way up
into 90
here so anyway guys that's what I've
been working on um for a while I there's
a few other indicators U we've been
working on but this one's been sucking
the life out of me um late nights you
know conversations with the programmer
getting everything working fine but
again you know reading the order flow my
opinion is the best really all
indicators do is help you understand
right it sort of takes the heavy lifting
off you know people ask me well what
what should I get should I get a
footprint or I should get indicators
well an
indicator right it just reads something
specific in the order flow okay so like
today right I was talking talking about
in the order flow ratio and Divergence
here but then I was talking about the
Deltas here okay that's two different
things so it's not all going to be the
same but if you're just looking at an
indicator you have to Define what it is
you're focusing on whereas when you're
looking at the order flow you sort of
have the flexibility to say I see
something else
developing in the order flow all right
so again guys I'm going to try to be a
little bit more proactive get some more
videos up for you I just want you to
know got proof of life I am alive I've
just been very busy with a lot of other
things um that I've just been wanted to
finish before the year end so thanks
everyone I'll catch you guys on the next
video bye-bye